[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée comme d'habitude de
l'actualité et des infos pratiques et
des idées de sortie sont au programme
voici les titres et de ce jeudi 4 mai
le nouveau souverain du Royaume-Uni
Charles III sera couronné ce samedi à
l'abbaye de Westminster à Londres
l'événement qui est une première pour le
pays depuis 1953 et le sacré d'Elisabeth
II sera observé dans le monde entier et
notamment dans les Yvelines du côté de
Croissy-sur-Seine la British School of
Paris s'y est installée depuis 1954 elle
délivra un enseignement 100% britannique
interview elle défendra les couleurs de
l'Île-de-France les 9 et 10 mai prochain
en Normandie l'inameziane étant finale
du concours du meilleur croissant au
beurre d'Isigny la jeune femme âgée de
16 ans est élève au lycée hôtelier de 50
ans en Yvelines à Guyancourt nous
l'avons suivi dans sa préparation pour
le rendez-vous
et puis même si les vacances de
printemps arrivent bientôt à leur terme
cela pourrait vous inspirer pour l'été
transformé votre utilitaire en un petit
camping-car cette société de Garancière
vous propose des kits clés en main pour
convertir votre véhicule évier module de
rangement ou encore lié amovible le tout
s'installe en 5 minutes chrono c'est la
promesse découverte de cette idée pour
s'évader dans le 7 8
il y a aussi donc ce week-end prolongé
du 8 mai qui va arriver entre
commémoration sortie et activités vous
nous dévoilerez tout à l'heure votre
sélection Céline Charles bonsoir jean-y
de la rédaction de TV 78 on va parler de
quoi ce soir oui justement un programme
varié donc on parlera bien sûr des
commémorations du 8 mai mais aussi de
sport de badminton pour être plus
précise de photos d'écriture et de
théâtre en ce début de weekend également
en tout cas ce sera demain on fera le
point aussi sur vos conditions de
circulation en Île-de-France avec les
prévisions de Bison Futé à vos côtés
Michael et nuit Doro bonsoir de la
rédaction TV 78 également vous allez
nous présenter vous dans quelques
instants les informations du jour ça
chauffe notamment autour du PSG de
Neymar de Neymar pas que Neymar un
messie également mais Neymar a Bougival
de plusieurs supporters sont venus
devant la maison de Neymar pour
protester leur mécontentement il a eu
lui demander tout simplement de partir
et on verra ça dans un sens et en face
de vous des invités ils ont fait
connaissance juste avant de commencer
cette émission c'est aussi ça le 7 8
hein c'est de susciter les par contre il
y a Christelle évidemment qui est avec
nous bonsoir vous êtes vous présidente
et fondatrice d'art partage.com c'est
une entreprise alors votre conviction à
vous c'est qu'il existe des passerelles
entre le monde de l'entreprise et de
l'art et vous allez nous parler de la
deuxième édition du swing art Cup c'est
le rendez-vous des constructeurs ça va
se passer le 11 mai prochain du côté du
golf de bettemont à Poissy en quelques
mots quel est le concept de l'événement
très convivial qui va mêler le monde des
affaires le monde du golf et la culture
et puis avec la thématique du bâtiment
du bâtiment cette année exactement c'est
le thème aussi de la première édition
c'était le thème de la première édition
et donc organisé par votre entreprise
art partage.com
c'est ce que je disais c'est de
favoriser les passerelles entre monde de
l'art monte de l'entreprise du business
des projets sur mesure avec les patrons
d'entreprise donc j'ai créé ma côté sur
le territoire de Saint-Quentin je vais
également sur le territoire du GPSO donc
côté
exactement et on est vraiment sur le
l'artère de de levier pour
travailler sur la sécurité sur les
thématiques de RSE on peut travailler
également sur des événements des des
anniversaires d'entreprise des
réalisations en communication que ce
soit de l'enseigne que ce soit des
supports de communication donc et puis
surtout avec les salariés donc ça c'est
important et on va en dire un peu plus
dans un instant on va vous donner aussi
de sortir dans les Yvelines faire une
petite balade à pied une randonnée
également à pied plus particulièrement
dans la vallée de Chevreuse puisque le
Comité Départemental de la Randonnée
Pédestre des Yvelines va lancer sa
première randovillage c'est ce dimanche
au départ de Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines
quatre parcours de randonnée pour
différents niveaux seront proposés à la
découverte aussi de quatre villages en
quatre villages qui seront traversés on
va en parler avec vous Hervé bonsoir
bonsoir président donc de ce Comité
Départemental de la Randonnée Pédestre
justement pour le présenter avant qu'on
parle du rando village qu'est-ce que le
comité départemental quels sont ces
missions tout simplement avec plaisir
bah le comité en dépend de la Fédération
Française de Randonnée nous gérons sur
le territoire des Yvelines plus de 1500
km de pair de GR et dgrp grâce à la
présence et la participation de 120 130
bénévoles gr g RP juste pour ceux qui ne
sont pas initiés
pédestre petite randonnée le tout avec
des bénévoles on imagine qui sont
primordial primordiaux même plus c'est
déterminant pour nous je suis moi-même
je suis moi-même bénévole et puis c'est
un paysage composé de 4500 licenciés sur
notre territoire des Yvelines et qui
appartiennent les uns des autres à 50 51
clubs dans notre département donc
beaucoup de possibilités là le focus est
fait sur la vallée de Chevreuse on va
avoir l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure avec cet événement randovillage
au menu également de ce 7 8 vous en avez
l'habitude parfois le jeudi la chronique
au poil datis barré qui vous vient qui
vient nous parler de bien-être animal et
ce soir cette chronique est consacrée au
cochon d'inde restez avec nous pour en
savoir plus mais coup d'oeil d'abord à
nos prévisions météo de demain
le temps va se dégrader peu à peu dans
la journée de vendredi pas dimanche
rassurez-vous pour la randonnée on va en
parler tout à l'heure un ciel parsemé le
matin vendredi avec des nuages et
peut-être quelques rayons de soleil côté
thermomètre il fera 14 degrés dans les
secteurs Nord et Centre du département
13 degrés à Rambouillet ça vire à
l'orage dans l'après-midi de vendredi
les Yvelines sont placés en vigilant
jaune par rapport par la météo France
entre 14h et 21h soyez vigilant les
températures elles sont un peu plus
fraîches qu'aujourd'hui 19 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie Oudon et Versailles 18
degrés dans le sud des Yvelines et
demain c'est la sainte juditée en fin
d'émission on vous donnera les
prévisions de ce week-end peut-être
meilleur on l'espère pour notamment la
Rand onnée à qui a lieu à dimanche et
c'est Thomas Fletcher un autre Mister
météo à nous qui vous livrera ses
prévisions météo décalées dans alors
quoi de beau on va faire le point tout
de suite sur les actualités du jour dans
les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Michael et on le
débute on débute cette ces informations
du jour avec les tensions autour du
Paris Saint-Germain plusieurs dizaines
de supporters en protesté devant le
domicile du joueur du
Paris-Saint-Germain à Neymar les raisons
de leur colère les mauvais résultats de
l'équipe et la politique du club sur
Instagram le joueur brésilien joue la
carte de l'apaisement en publiant je
cite ne laissez pas les gens vous mettre
dans leur tempête mettez-les dans votre
paix de son côté le PSG a condamné dans
un communiqué ses agissements et apporte
son soutien l'équipe et son encadrement
le club annonce aussi renforcer les
dispositifs de sécurité aux abords du
centre d'entraînement et devant la
maison de certains joueurs parisiens et
donc de Neymar vous disiez tout à
l'heure à Neymar qui habite la commune
de Bougival dans les Yvelines on va
poursuivre ces infos avec une vente aux
enchères du côté de Versailles jusqu'au
17 mai la ville de Versailles organise
une vente aux enchères sur internet pour
les bien ayant plus d'utilité pour les
services de la commune tableau a créé
chaise ou tondeuse l'occasion sont
proposées au public il y en a pour
toutes les bourses puisque les tarifs
aussi entre 10 et 6000 euros il est
possible de venir voir les produits au
centre technique municipal à Versailles
rendez-vous sur le site AgoraStore.fr
pour voir les différentes offres
disponibles on l'a appris ce matin un
comédien yvelin fait partie du jury du
Festival de Cannes qui aura lieu du 16
au 27 mai prochain le comédien Yvelines
wa Denis menocher sous le feu des
projecteurs aux côtés de la réalisatrice
marocaine Mariam Touzani ou de la
scénariste rongano myomi l'acteur fera
partie des joueurs des membres du jury
du 76e Festival de Cannes il avait
notamment fait une apparition dans le
film Inglourious Bastard de Quentin
Tarantino et obtenu un Goya du meilleur
acteur pour asbestas de Rodrigo Soro
goyenne selon le confrères de
Première.fr le comédien aurait grandi à
Feucherolles dans les Yvelines la fermer
colle graine d'avenir bientôt dotée d'un
internat l'ouvrira en internat à la
rentrée 2023 au sein du site de
formation pour je vous rappelle cet
établissement situé dans la ferme de
bulloyer forme jusqu'à 12 jeunes âgés de
plus de 15 ans au métier de maraîcher
primeur 6 places seront disponibles dans
l'internat pour accueillir en semaine
les élèves de l'école la fin des
vacances de pâques approche combinée à
un weekend prolongé du 8 mai résultat
sur les routes ça risque d'être ce
weekend à décevant vendredi à Bison Futé
voir rouge dans le sens des départs et
vert pour les retours des difficultés
qui commenceront dès la fin de matinée
dans les Yvelines au niveau des
autoroutes A10 à 13 et à 86 la situation
restera très difficile jusqu'en fin de
soirée pour la journée de samedi Bison
Futé prévoit du orange pour les départs
et du vert pour les retours des
difficultés qui devraient se prolonger
jusqu'en début d'après-midi après une
accalmie pour le reste de la journée ce
dimanche la situation s'inverse et
devient verte pour les départs et orange
pour les retours des ralentissements
devraient se faire sentir dès le milieu
d'après-midi sur la 10 et enfin pour ce
lundi férié les difficultés
s'accentueront avec du rouge dans le
sens des retours prévoyez de partir en
début de matinée pour éviter ces
complications car les bouchons se
poursuivront jusqu'à la nuit un temps
d'attente important aux barrières de
péage est attendu à Grégory merci
Michael et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'un fait qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez
pas à le partager sur les réseaux
sociaux en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
petit tour de table auprès de mes
invités je vais pas faire participer les
journalistes parce que ils ont participé
à la préparation de cette émission ce
serait de la tricherie ce que vous savez
ce qu'il se passe samedi comme événement
retentissant
Hervé Christelle non
le couronnement de Charles
quiz aujourd'hui mais vous avez remporté
le bon point pour cette petite question
du quiz effectivement 8 mois après la
mort d'Elisabeth II son fils le roi
Charles III sera officiellement sacré ce
samedi à la tête du Royaume-Uni la
cérémonie du couronnement se tiendra en
l'abbaye de Westminster à Londres et
sera suivi de deux jours de fête dans le
pays pour cause on n'avait pas vu pareil
événement depuis 1953 de l'autre côté de
la Manche Michael vous êtes rendu avec
Patrick Jacques de dixmut cet après-midi
elle a British call of Paris oui c'est à
Croissy-sur-Seine et c'est une école
quasiment essentiellement britannique
avec quelques personnes quand même qui
viennent de d'autres pays mais qui sont
qui sont présents dans cette école pour
l'enseignement de la culture britannique
il porte notamment à des uniformes et on
a pu les rencontrer du coup sur place et
il nous parle de ce couronnement et on
va regarder tout de suite effectivement
votre interview parce que forcément sur
place on se prépare ce samedi 6 mai ce
sera un événement à planétaire le roi
Charles III sera couronné à Westminster
à Londres mais l'événement sera aussi
très suivi dans les Yvelines à la
British School of Paris l'un des
endroits peut-être les plus britanniques
des Yvelines à mes côtés de professeurs
des écoles à British School of Paris Joe
et Caroline alors est-ce que c'est un
événement très important pour l'école
oui bien sûr parce que ça fait partie de
nos cultures et c'est une nouvelle
montre préhistorique c'est je pense que
40 quantième monarche du pays donc
depuis Milan donc c'est très important
et on va la fêter bien sûr c'est c'est
bien pour la culture voilà oui on le
voit il y a beaucoup de drapeaux ici
vous avez également des petits drapeaux
au dessus de votre tête est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui va être organisé ici à la
brutuschkov Paris en fait demain on va
avoir un street parti dans l'école et tu
les enfants et les parents sont invités
et ils avaient déjà fait un peu plus de
préparations les parents il va même du
du des choses pour le street party et
les enfants ils ont appris de chanter
god save the king bien sûr c'est un
petit changement et ils sont très
contents il va être déguisés en bleu
blanc rouge il va pour télécharger comme
des lunettes il va avoir des draps il va
avoir de la musique qui va avoir la
danse et ils sont très excités pour ça
oui c'est un événement très suivi au
sein de l'école et pour les parents
aussi ah oui les parents de l'école sont
invités il y a plus que de père qui va
être là et j'essaye peut-être ce weekend
aussi il y a des parents qui organisent
les fêtes chez eux et même que il y a
pas tous les enfants bien sûr qui sont
britanniques mais en fait c'est une fête
qu'on partage ensemble on a bu que des
nationalités ici mais c'est
en Grande-Bretagne on aime bien faire
les choses ensemble
et voilà ça on est en école
internationale et c'est quelque chose
qu'on va fêter ensemble vous organisez
cet événement depuis longtemps on le
sait depuis quelques deux semaines cette
date du 6 mai à 11h20 exactement pour
l'arrivée du roi Charles à Westminster
on l'a connaît depuis quelques semaines
est-ce que vous préparez cet événement
depuis quelques semaines également ah
oui depuis quelques temps c'est quelque
chose que on a organisé et on parle avec
les enfants de ça il y a voilà c'est
toute une préparation peut-être pas eux
aussi qu'en Angleterre pour le vrai
corps humain mais en Afrique du temps
vous êtes professeur toutes les deux
est-ce qu'il vous en parle les enfants
oui de temps en temps il pose des
questions surtout ceux qui sont moins en
famille avec des événements ils veulent
savoir exactement ce que c'est donc on a
expliqué ou que c'est une grande fête en
fait et c'est après les périodes de
deuil de la Reine Elizabeth donc
maintenant c'est le prince Charles
et c'est la grande fête alors au niveau
de la tradition il y aura un plat qui
fait beaucoup parler de lui la quiche du
couronnement qu'est-ce que c'est et
est-ce que vous ici vous vous allez
faire cette fameuse quiche du
couronnement oui en fait on a donné un
lien à l'écran pour le coronation quiche
et c'est un quiche qui a du épinard du
fèves et du estragon et on attend de moi
j'ai jamais goûté ça alors c'est on va
attendre pour voir comment
tu la crème
confiture très régulièrement en
Angleterre donc c'est ça aussi
après la reine Victoria en fait alors je
le précise ça sera les petits qui vont
faire la fête ici les grands juste à
côté sont eux en examen par contre ah
oui c'est ça oui ils sont plein examen
et voilà alors pour eux il va avoir
quelques-unes qui sont en train de faire
des examens alors c'est que pour les
petits ici est-ce que l'histoire de la
reine d'Angleterre des rois d'Angleterre
est enseigné ici est-ce qu'on en parle
beaucoup
oui ou en fait on parle de l'histoire
entre marginale parce qu'en fait on a
une grande ligne avec tuletta c'est avec
plein de choses événements dans
l'histoire et bien sûr les rennes et roi
de l'Angleterre sont partis de ça mais
aussi de les autres pays aussi
et samedi vous serez où vous toutes les
deux est-ce que vous allez la regarder
en fait moi je vais attendre Normandie
avec une couple
bilingue voilà anglais-français et je
suis sûr qu'on va faire quelques on va
regarder oui avec une quiche peut-être
tu dois essayer et vous Caroline vous
allez regarder le également le
couronnement oui je vais regarder et je
sais que j'ai des amis en Paypal qui
vont se mettre en des amis mais qui sont
hollandais en fait donc il y a beaucoup
de gens qui qui vont regarder samedi
ouais moi certainement oui et qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez justement de ce roi
Charles moi je pense qu'il est bien
préparé pour le rôle je pensais je ne
connais pas personnellement évidemment
mais je pense il a beaucoup d'expérience
et il est à l'écoute des gens ce que
l'impression qu'il donne et cultiver moi
je pense ça va bien
aussi je pensais quelqu'un qui pense
plus que à l'environnement
et architecture de l'avenir de les
jeunes de légende en Angleterre et et
aussi voilà
et
j'essaie je pense qu'il aime bien de
l'or Ilana nature est-ce qu'on peut
terminer par un peut-être god save the
king
et le couronnement du roi Charles III ce
sera donc ce samedi 6 mai à 11h20
environ ici on fera la fête demain et on
l'a compris dans toutes les familles
vinoises on fera également la fête
devant sa télé
est-ce que vous allez suivre l'événement
autour de la table le couronnement de
Charles III parce que ça vous intéresse
ou vous en êtes totalement indifférent
un balisage temporaire dans les quatre
villages oui il y a du travail en vue de
la rando village il y a du terrain
un peu pareil avec la
switch royale du
la journée a débutera aux alentours de
11h20 par une procession de Charles III
en compagnie de son épouse qui a mis la
parkerballs du palais royal jusqu'à
l'abbaye de Westminster et donc la
cérémonie du couronnement devrait
débuter elle a 12h en présence de plus
de 2000 invités on va faire une
rencontre après présent dans le 7 8 avec
Lina médiane c'est vous qui l'avez
rencontré justement Céline Charles elle
est élève au lycée hôtelier de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à
aguilloncourt elle sera l'une des deux
représentantes de l'Île-de-France pour
la finale du meilleur croissant au
beurre désigne AOP la finale se passe et
du côté de la Normandie les 9 et 10 mai
prochain vous l'avez suivi justement ces
lignes durant sa préparation
il a le goût des vacances ou des
dimanches matin le croissant et la
viennoiserie française par excellence
mais le confectionner à la perfection et
tout un art chaque année depuis 18 ans
le concours du meilleur croissant au
beurre désigny AOP récompense les
apprenants boulangers de moins de 20 ans
le 28 mars dernier c'est Lina Méziane
qui a remporté la sélection régionale
elle est élève en deuxième année bac pro
boulangerie pâtisserie au lycée hôtelier
de Guyancourt elle représentera
l'Île-de-France lors de la finale le 9
et 10 mai prochain en Normandie c'était
mon premier concours donc moi je partais
pour voilà pour gagner mais je voulais
aussi surtout engranger de l'expérience
et bah
j'ai vu quand j'ai vu que j'ai remporté
la finale régionale j'étais super
contente
je voulais absolument faire ce concours
de pleine dernière quand mes profs on
avait parlé donc j'étais impatiente et
pour moi c'est mon premier concours donc
forcément
c'est une expérience que je voulais
avoir
tournage détaillage façonnage cuisson
faire un bon croissant de s'improvise
pas Lina on a bien conscience elle
s'entraîne sans relâche depuis plus d'un
mois il faut être patient minutieux
pointilleux faut voilà faut faire
attention à tous les petits détails et
il faut être très rigoureux aussi donc
là ce que je vais faire pour avoir
justement cette régularité c'est que je
vais mesurer je vais mesurer mon abaisse
pour que elle fasse un certain nombre de
centimètres et qu'ensuite tous mes
croissants soient au même nombre
cependant qu'on a cours on a deux TP par
semaine et pendant cette épée là de 5
heures ben moi j'étais dans une pièce à
part où je m'entraînais que sur ça que
sur les croissants et ensuite bah là
comme vous voyez pendant les vacances
aussi je veux bien pour la finale Ina
devra réaliser 12 croissants et une
viennoiserie créative de son choix pour
cela elle peut compter sur les conseils
avisés de son professeur il
l'accompagnera le jour J en Normandie
Lina c'est une battante Lina c'est une
compétitrice donc j'avais pas tout ce
côté à gérer elle s'est elle sait où
elle veut aller elle sait où elle va
après vikeva il le résultat sera on
verra bien quoi j'ai toujours aimé
cuisiner avec ma maman j'ai toujours vu
cuisiner j'ai su depuis toute petite que
je voulais être pâtissière et oui ça en
fait ça a toujours été une évidence pour
moi goût esthétique dextérité
originalité ou encore régularité rien ne
sera laissé au hasard le gagnant de la
sélection nationale remportera un stage
animé par un meilleur ouvrier de France
réponse dans quelques jours
l'action que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est est-ce que vous avez pu goûter à
ce croissant il faut savoir que faire un
croissant c'est très très long et quand
je l'ai quitté elle était seulement en
train de faire reposer la pâte mais
seulement c'est quand même quelques
heures avant de pouvoir faire la cuisson
donc voilà c'est long en tout cas on
écoutant ces professeurs a priori elle
aurait toutes ses chances pour remporter
la victoire c'est en plus faut savoir
qu'elle est également athlète de haut
niveau en car en karaté et du coup voilà
c'est vraiment la la gérer la pression
moi je l'ai vu elle avait pas l'air
stressée elle avait l'air vraiment
confiante on lui souhaite en tout cas
bonne chance à l'inameziane qui
représentera donc l'Île-de-France la
semaine prochaine en Normandie faire se
rencontrer le monde des affaires plus
particulièrement celui du bâtiment avec
l'art et la culture c'est le but de la
swing art Cup la deuxième édition de cet
événement se tient jeudi 11 mai au golf
de bettemont à Poissy Christelle
évidemment est avec nous pour parler de
cet événement que vous organisez avec
votre entreprise art partage.com alors
vous nous expliquer tout la valeur le
concept et vous commencez à avancer
pourquoi il était intéressant de faire
des passerelles justement entre les deux
mondes finalement la culture l'art ça
peut donner des clés pour la réussite
dans le monde du business de
l'entreprise
c'est aussi un outil de bien-être et
créatif aussi c'est à dire que on
s'aperçoit que quand on mène un atelier
par exemple au sein du d'une entreprise
on peut avoir un collaborateur qui va
exprimer quelque chose qu'il n'aurait
pas osé exprimer et justement le côté le
côté art casse un peu les barrières et
ouvre les champs des possibles dans dans
l'expression de soi et de et de ce qui
peut gêner en fait sur un sujet bien
précis que ce soit sécurité ou RSE mais
ça libère en fait ça libère l'émotionnel
ça libère la création et puis et puis
aussi c'est un mode collaboratif et
participatif vous avez dans une
entreprise souvent tout est cloisonné
vous avez les services comptabilité les
services
commercial et en fait on rassemble tout
le monde par par la culture donc c'est
c'est ça permet aux personnes aussi
également de
se mélanger et de discuter autour de
d'un sujet
pour lequel ils ont pas forcément
l'habitude et vous avez ressenti ça
aussi auprès des participants il y avait
je crois une soixantaine de participants
l'année dernière alors l'année dernière
ce qui était oui parce que là je
m'éloignais un petit peu là j'étais
j'étais plutôt en mode entreprise par
rapport à votre question enfin au sein
de l'entreprise en fait quand on mène un
événement c'est un événement de business
donc d'affaires le fait de le faire sur
un golf c'est très convivial et puis
encore une fois ça casse les barrières
et le fait d'y mettre de la culture moi
je avec mon métier je voudrais de plus
en plus travailler dans le monde du
bâtiment j'ai commencé à 50 ans en
Yvelines par le bâtiment du New Wave on
avait mis une oeuvre d'art dans le hall
d'accueil et en fait les gens vont
discuter s'appréhender d'une autre façon
pas comme dans un une soirée de business
qui va se faire ou ou un BNI ou quelque
chose qui est qui est totalement
différent mais là on est dans une un
format beaucoup plus je vais pas dire
que les autres formats ne sont pas
conviviaux on l'a compris ça casse les
cotes plutôt ça qui sont les
participants qui seront présents alors
on a des des architectes on a des
promoteurs immobiliers alors est-ce que
je dois citer tout le monde on a des
on a des gens qui étaient là l'année
dernière on a entreprises de bâtiment
patrimoine et rénovation un bureau
d'études PACS ingénie l'année dernière
mais aussi peut-être de nous
participants également et puis sans
oublier les partenaires sponsors qui qui
sont là qui sont eux un peu transversaux
au niveau de leur de leur domaine
d'activité je pense à des LG alors sur
le territoire principalement de de
Poissy je pense également à y fimo
d'entreprise bon là c'est un partenaire
entreprise et puis et puis vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la Vallée de Chevreuse
on a pour la première fois les couvreurs
de la Vallée de Chevreuse qui se sont
joints à nous donc
exactement alors ils vont pouvoir jouer
au golf parce que on est présent sur un
sur un golf il y a aussi des artistes
qui vont être présents des rencontres
qui vont être aussi suscités au gré de
la journée alors en fait au niveau du
golf c'est pas on n'a pas voulu que ce
soit non plus une compétition de golf
parce que c'était pas ça l'idée mais
néanmoins on a des participants qui vont
pouvoir faire cette année un 18 trous
pour ceux qui sont golfeurs parce que
la pétanque du golf et puis on a
l'initiation pour les débutants du coup
exactement mais tout l'intérêt c'est
qu'ils sont également en nombre et ça
permet de de leur alors on va leur
montrer les rudiments du golf mais
également d'être en mini compétition à
trois à deux ou à trois ça va dépendre
un peu de des organisateurs et puis
effectivement l'art aussi puisque on a
deux artistes on a Hubert privé qui est
bien connu du monde du Golfe et on voit
son trophée il a imaginé le trophée de
l'année dernière donc cet événement on
l'avait vu à l'écran
et puis donc Hubert privé cette année
j'ai je viens avec berthewan qui est un
street artiste et qui est un créateur de
bande dessinée alors je dévoile pas tout
parce que il nous a concocté quelque
chose pour les participants et puis sans
oublier deux autres personnes la petite
surprise aussi cette année c'est à
romainvignis qui vient donc il va faire
qui va proposer une dégustation sur le
terrain de 20 qui sont
comment dire c'est une c'est une société
familiale depuis 1818 sans me tromper et
en fait elle va il crée leur saveur ils
créent leur avec les avec les
viticulteurs donc ils vont être ils vont
être présents à nous faire goûter
côté à tous les participants se cépages
et puis les prodigieux qui est une
société de macarons et je me tairai sur
le sujet pour pas trop en dire aussi
pour réserver la petite fille
il sera là et puis oui oui tout à fait
oui oui on compte bien le
pérenniser complètement et quels sont
les objectifs ce qui feraient que la
journée soit une nouvelle réussite pour
cette deuxième édition vous diriez les
ingrédients de la réussite
c'est qu'il soit content d'être là
quelle que soit j'ai envie de dire quel
que soit le nombre c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt le les regards le fait qu'ils
aient quand ils arrivent qu'ils soient
déjà bien accueillis après le dialogue
avec les différents participants
l'accueil du petit déjeuner enfin c'est
un peu les sourires oui au-delà du du
soleil
parce que l'année dernière on a une
journée magnifique il faisait très très
beau là je sais pas les prévisions
météorologiques mais bon en tout cas où
il a réussi le fait que de voir les ce
serait ça et puis encore une fois ce qui
est important c'est je parlais de
business tout à l'heure on voit que
l'année dernière ça a généré des
connexions en fait de business on le
sait après on va les on va aller voir on
on ne sait pas forcément quand on est
dans l'organisation on voit pas
forcément les sur place ce qui se passe
et comme on est un petit peu un petit
peu partout donc on voit pas forcément
les les conséquences tout de suite mais
en tout cas l'année dernière eu des
connexions business et c'est sur le
territoire territoire Poissy donc voilà
et donc la deuxième édition est
programmée jeudi prochain ce sera le 11
mai du côté du golf de bettemont à
Poissy pour donc la deuxième édition de
cette swing art cut merci d'être venu en
parler en plateau mais vous restez bien
sûr avec nous est-ce que vous avez déjà
fait autour de la table vos plans pour
l'été vous savez déjà vous allez partir
en vacances cet été ou peut-être que
vous n'avez pas avoir la chance de
partir en vacances je ne sais pas une
grande randonnée grande randonnée je
suis en train de préparer c'est le tour
du massif des écrins de l'Oisans j'ai
déjà réservé lesquins les 15 refuges
vous êtes pas camping-car autour de la
table par hasard non pas du tout bon une
idée en tout cas qu'on va vous donner
dans le 7 8 pour s'évader avec le retour
des beaux jours c'est de convertir son
véhicule utilitaire en un meetni en un
mini camping-car pour voyager une
société située à Garancières propose de
vous y aider évier module de rangement
ou encore les modulable des kit
universels sont livrés directement à
domicile au domicile du client pour un
montage garant i en 5 minutes chrono
découverte pour les baroudeurs dans
l'âme avec Julien Leroy
bienvenue dans l'atelier nolty où nous
assemblons préparons l'intégralité des
aménagements s'évader à moindre coût
pour ces vacances c'est la promesse de
nolti spécialisée dans la conception de
kit amovible pour véhicules utilitaire
cuisine couchage rangement la société
située aujourd'hui à Garancières a été
fondée en 2018 elle propose un mobilier
universel s'adaptant à la plupart des
habitacles objectifs rendre le milieu du
caramaning moins onéreux si on arrivait
pour faire simple à créer un aménagement
et de le pouvoir le proposer à un tarif
ma voisinant les 2500 euros avec la
literie et l'expédition c'était Paris
gagné seul quelques inserts métalliques
sont placés dans le plancher par la
société nolti le kit en bois peuplier
est ensuite livré sur palette au
domicile de l'acheteur et fixé grâce à
ses visuels l'idée c'était vraiment de
créer un aménagement amovible que les
clients puissent installer au bord de
leur propre véhicule et sans outilillage
ce client désiré voyager de manière
spontanée pose de vitrage feutrine
habillage bois pour environ 5000 euros
son véhicule utilitaire a pu être
aménagé pour lui permettre de partir en
week-end donc là vous avez un couchage
d'un mètre 80 sur 120 large OK et
ensuite l'intégralité des matelas qui
viennent tout simplement se positionner
de cette façon je voulais un kit qui
soit qui fasse le vraiment la double
utilité je passe du côté camion
camionnette aux côtés vannes très très
rapidement et c'est surtout que c'est
nettement moins cher qu'un camping-car
ou quoi que ce soit donc il y a un côté
économique et écologique d'autant plus
voilà de plutôt que d'avoir
effectivement un van
aménagé de façon fixe pour s'en servir 4
à 5 semaines par an et tout le reste du
temps qui soit stationné à son domicile
on trouvait ça un petit peu dommage avec
une demande croissante depuis la
pandémie de covid 19 la société nolti
expedime quinzaine de kits chaque mois
chez ses clients un besoin de prendre la
route pour s'évader et aller à
l'aventure
allez c'est l'heure à présent de la
chronique au poil d'Athis barré
[Musique]
en plateau bonsoir à this conseillère
municipal de Poissy délégué au bien-être
animal alors après les chiens après le
lapin vous étiez venu aussi avec un
lapin ce soir c'est avec un cochon
d'inde que vous êtes venus pour nous
parler justement de cet animal comment
s'en occuper vous allez nous donner tous
vos bons conseils déjà une petite fiche
d'identité qui est-il oui alors c'est
Roméo donc qui est qui est un petit
cochon d'Inde qui n'est ni un cochon et
ni un indien en fait c'est Christophe
Colomb qui croyait être en Inde et avec
les navigateurs comme le cochon d'inde
et Queen et ben ils ont surnommé le
cochon d'inde voilà j'ai offert un petit
descriptif que de nos cochons d'Inde qui
sont très adoptés par les familles
françaises on les appelle d'ailleurs les
NAC ce sont les nouveaux animaux de
compagnie donc c'est des animaux je
parle doucement parce que c'est des
animaux qui sont vraiment très craintifs
ils ont donc
au niveau de la vision il voit en noir
et blanc au niveau niveau des incisives
donc leurs incisives elles poussent
constamment et puis ils ont un odorat
qui est très développé ils vont
reconnaître leur congénères à l'odeur de
leur urine et ils aiment vivre par deux
donc dès que vous avez un cochon d'inde
c'est mieux de les avoir par deux ils
vont ils vivront plus longtemps quel âge
a-t-il Il a 2 ans et demi Romeo 2 ans et
demi et vous nous disiez au niveau du
caractère le cochon d'inde est en
général craintif oui alors il a un sacré
caractère pas vrai qu'on Romeo c'est un
ils sont craintifs en fait ils ont un
caractère qui est un peu donnant-donnant
donc ils aiment beaucoup l'attention les
caresses et si vous ne lui donnez pas
beaucoup d'attention il va vous donner
des coups de pâte avec ses pattes
arrières également des jets d'urine et
par contre à l'inverse donc c'est un
animal qui est très intelligent si vous
lui rendez bien il va vous le rendre en
couinant il va vous le rendre vraiment
avec des câlins et puis donc c'est un
très bon communicant il a eu beaucoup la
vie en groupe il est au niveau donc au
niveau du contact avec
on génère ça va être le contact buccal
ils vont même se renifler le train
arrière les uns les autres c'est pour ça
chaque émission je vous dis attention à
l'obésité de votre animal ça va couper
le lien social avec les autres
et du coup un animal fragile on
l'imagine un animal très fragile comme
il est petit de taille sa queue mais
toute petite il y a que cet OS il faut
faire attention à l'eau froide pour pas
qu'il n'y ait la diarrhée et puis à son
alimentation donc faut veiller à ce
qu'il est beaucoup de fruits de légumes
c'est un bon modèle pour les maris et
les enfants et il faut surtout qu'il ait
beaucoup de foin pour sa digestion
pour justement entretenir Roméo pour
prendre soin de lui et puis au niveau
cardiaque comme il est très craintif il
faut éviter la crise cardiaque qu'il ait
une cachette au niveau de son habitat où
il pourra se réfugier donc comment on
s'en occupe très concrètement alors
commençons notre cube donc avoir une
grande cage beaucoup communiquer avec
lui chaque fois que vous passez dans sa
cage lui donner des belles paroles donc
ce qui est bien c'est que ça apprendra
aussi aux enfants de s'habituer à être
bienveillant envers les autres mais vous
le disiez alors en général c'est mieux
quand ils sont deux c'est pas un animal
solitaire vaut mieux qu'il y a quelqu'un
avec lui c'est ça c'est un animal il
vaut mieux et qu'il ait quelqu'un avec
lui qui soit entouré c'est le seul
animal d'ailleurs qui peut vivre avec 5
à 10 congénères donc veillez bien à le
stériliser et puis surtout jamais de mal
dans une même cage avec une femelle là
c'est le j'ai d'urine assuré dans votre
habitation est-ce qu'on peut avoir
d'autres animaux de compagnie alors au
niveau de un lapin oui par contre avec
le chien et chat ça fera mauvais de
ménage Romeo lui il est à l'étage et le
chien est en bas la durée de vie d'un
cochon d'inde alors la durée de vie ça
varie en fait en fonction de son habitat
entre 4 ans à 8 ans et puis en fonction
de comment vous allez le considérer dans
la famille donc et puis surtout veillez
à sa dentition l'occlusion buccale est
très très importante visiblement on pose
beaucoup de questions dans l'oreillette
on est intéressé par le cochon d'inde
est-ce qu'on peut le mettre dans son
jardin le cochon d'inde est-ce qu'on
peut le sortir de sa cage ou c'est pas
recommandé alors il peut sortir de sa
cage puisqu'il vit un famille en plus il
vit aux mêmes horaires que vous en
journée donc oui oui tant qu'il y a pas
dedans j'ai et il faut l'habituer en
fait au lieu et il sort rarement le
cochon est-ce que c'est un compagnon
idéal pour les enfants oui très idéal
pour les enfants parce qu'il est très
malléable alors les enfants surtout
attention quand vous le manipulez à ne
pas faire tomber le cochon d'inde et
puis c'est un animal donc qui aime
beaucoup l'attention donc ça c'est bien
pour pour les enfants et peut-être faire
des statistiques voir les gens qui ont
des cochons d'inde ils sont peut-être
tourné vers les autres peut-être dans le
médical ça j'aimerais bien faire une
petite cycle là dessus
l'adoption commence à se passe pour le
cochon d'inde alors en animalerie au
niveau des associations
où il y a beaucoup de naissances Roméo
lui par exemple il a été pris un
animalerie et un coup de foudre avec
Héloïse et Roméo au vu de sa jolie
houpette et puis Romeo lui a un mélomane
ou il adore la musique puisque Éloïse en
fait est une grande danseuse elle a
obtenu un prix elle a eu le 9e prix
Nijinski du Concours International de
Danse donc voilà Roméo je pense qu'il a
vu très longtemps merci beaucoup à Athis
pour tous ces bons conseils sur le
cochon d'inde merci à Roméo qui a été
très calme très sage il couine un tout
petit peu juste avant le début mais il
s'est il s'est calmé caresser pour
éviter les gîtes d'urine sur moi autour
de la table vous avez des cochons d'inde
vous en avez déjà eu non non voilà bon
j'en avais eu deux bon voilà en tout cas
tous les bons conseils merci beaucoup à
this barré vous vous revenez nous parler
de quoi la prochaine fois de qui la
tombe des moutons la semaine prochaine
c'est la période d'accord bon on vous
retrouve en tout cas la semaine
prochaine merci beaucoup pour tous ces
bons conseils et on va maintenant ouvrir
la page loisirs des idées de sortie dans
le 7 8
[Musique]
ce week-end on va arpenter le territoire
à pied pour découvrir les Yvelines les
possibilités sont nombreuses on disait
avec vous tout à l'heure Hervé
malcorpique et président et du comité
départemental de randonnée pédestre des
Yvelines alors ce weekend vous organisez
plus précisément dimanche le rando
village c'est en Vallée de Chevreuse on
pourra découvrir vraiment la vallée de
Chevreuse avec cette première dans le
département au programme quatre
randonnées selon les niveaux au départ
de Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines découvrir
quatre communes des Yvelines on parle de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines bien sûr mais
aussi de son champ Rochefort-en-Yvelines
et Clairefontaine on va détailler les
parcours dans un instant mais pourquoi
proposer ce rendez-vous tout simplement
quels sont les objectifs déjà c'est une
histoire enfin une rencontre avec le PNR
de la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse puisque
nous avons pris il y a un an un an et
demi la gestion de leur 130 de leur
entente km ce qui nous a permis enfin au
bénévoles et moi-même d'arpenter
d'arpenter ce beau parc naturel et
ensuite donc j'ai pris mon bâton de
pèlerin bon c'est Hervé je suis pas
Saint-Jacques et j'ai rencontré les
quatre mères des quatre des quatre
villages donc de Rochefort
Clairefontaine son champ et
Saint-Arnoult est vraiment un bel
enthousiasme de leur part prêt à
accueillir ce genre de ce genre
d'événements sur les territoires de leur
commune alors il y aura quatre parcours
proposés de 13 à 27 km ça veut dire que
ça s'adresse à tout le monde même si on
n'a pas vraiment fait de randonnée on
peut quand même venir découvrir et faire
le plus petit parcours alors ça
s'adresse aux familles au licencier au
non licencié c'est donc 5 euros
d'inscription pour une personne et 10
euros pour deux personnes et au-delà et
bah les parcours c'est un parcours qui
commence à 13 km et qui se termine pour
le dernier parcours à 27 km donc sachant
qu'à randonneurs une façon générale
c'est 3 km 5 à l'heure donc c'est
vraiment ouvert à tout le monde vous
avez bien révisé le contenu des parcours
parce que je voulais les aborder
les parcours c'est on va démarrer avec
le parcours le plus long qui fait 27,5
km 320 mètres de dénivelé on appelle ça
le circuit des trois villages alors là
c'est plutôt pour les randonneurs quand
même de très bon niveau qui sont avertis
c'est à dire que les inscriptions
débutent de 8h30 jusqu'à 11h donc
sachant que cette grande boucle depuis
27 km s'adresse déjà des bons bons
randonneurs puisque finalement ils vont
marcher pendant
7-8 heures quoi donc on les attend avec
du café des 8h30 et ensuite ils vont
parcourir à loisir donc les quatre
villages qui composent cette cette se
rend au village donc on l'a dit à
saint-anne-en-yvelines au lieu du départ
son champ Rochefort-en-Yvelines et
Clairefontaine alors et j'ajoute et
j'ajoute que certains nous est le point
de départ mais également le point
d'arrivée des quatre boucles avec des
animations on va en parler dans dans un
instant notamment un concert qui est au
programme circuit des deux villages là
c'est 22,5 km 255 mètres de dénivelé
voilà c'est ça et donc c'est c'est 5h 5
à 5 heures de marche là encore pour
avoir un bon niveau faut avoir un bon
niveau mais on n'est pas dans les Alpes
en tout de même les dîner comme vous
l'avez indiqué sont relativement limités
bon voilà c'est c'est c'est
je crois que c'est ouvert à s'est ouvert
malgré tout ou famille qui qui ont
l'habitude de randonnée qui ont
l'habitude de randonner dimanche je
rappelle tout de même qu'en France il y
a plus de 25 millions de marcheurs tout
de même donc il y en a un potentiel
assez assez important pour ce genre de
d'événements je crois qu'il y en a
autour de la table des marchés
16,5 km 130 m de de dénivelé là donc du
coup bah son champ on part de
saint-amand-en-yvelines on va découvrir
son champ en plus voilà alors c'est
c'est pour ceux qui ont l'habitude de se
lever tard tard le dimanche ils peuvent
se présenter donc jusqu'à 10h30 jusqu'à
10h30 arrivée à à 10h du matin à
Saint-Arnoult et faire la boucle avec
avec son champ et donc le dernier
parcours Rochefort circuit de Rochefort
13,5 km là donc du coup si on est
débutant on se dirige vers celui-là
c'est un an et demi pour pour atteindre
la belle place et le beau la belle
mairie de de Rochefort-en-Yvelines et de
revenir quoi et de et de se restaurer
dans un food truck donc ça permet bien
sûr on l'a vu au gré des images de
découvrir la Vallée de Chevreuse il y a
notamment la maison Elsa Triolet Aragon
de Saint-Amand Yvelines d'autres points
vous l'avez dit 4 villages qui sont à
découvrir d'ailleurs pour ces randonnées
il y a la possibilité de les faire seul
en groupe mais il y a aussi une version
accompagnée c'est ça et c'est à dire que
il y a quelqu'un du comité qui va nous
accompagner dans cette randonnée au
niveau de l'organisation dans dans
chaque village donc les membres du
comité seront présents concrètement ces
tables chaises barnum mais également
food truck quatre villages 4 food trucks
qui sont installés des 10 heures jusqu'à
16h et
donc ils auront l'objet de la
possibilité de de gérer de s'alimenter
et puis également on a passé un accord
enfin les partenariats sont nombreux
avec le comité rural et sportif du
département des Yvelines qui qui
animeront ces quatre ces quatre ces
quatre villages pendant toute la durée
de pendant toute la durée de l'événement
parce qu'il y a des animations tout au
long de la journée notamment alors celle
que j'ai retenu mon attention c'est
celle qui a lieu à 17h pour la fin de la
journée il y a un concert de l'Orchestre
Philharmonique des Yvelines alors ça
sera le point d'orgue ce sera le point
d'or et ça serait un bonhomme bien sûr
donc l'Orchestre Philharmonique des
Yvelines sera présent avec plus de 45 45
concertistes qui arriveront dès 7h30 du
matin donc on va on va aider à installer
le chapiteau et les estrades donc ils
auront le grand plaisir de jouer la
Troisième Symphonie de Beethoven Carmen
de Bizet
les chariots de feu donc c'est un
concert qui va durer une heure et quart
1h30 et puis également l'autre événement
c'est que dans le cas de nos accords
avec le Conseil départemental
il y aura également un ingénieur
forestier qui sera basé dans les
hauteurs de la forêt de Rochefort et qui
parlera de prévention et les biotopes
spécifiques à l'eau de vallée de
Chevreuse très rapidement vous l'avez
dit le prix de l'inscription 5 euros 5
euros et on vient avec un équipement
spécifique avec des bonnes marches de
randonnée des bonnes chaussures de et
voilà et de la contemplation vers vers
ce beau PNR alors toutes les
informations bien sûr sur le site
internet qu'on va voir ce réafficher à
nouveau pour donc cet événement un rando
village qui a lieu ce dimanche au départ
de Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines très
rapidement allez-y donc assez internaute
donc point de départ et qu'on est arrivé
donc la présence du conseil
départemental de Rambouillet territoire
du PNR de la haute venez de Chevreuse et
le comité rural et sportif du
département et bien sûr notre comité
départemental merci Hervé pour toutes
ces précisions alors on va rester
justement en Vallée de Chevreuse plus
précisément du côté du château de la
Madeleine à l'occasion du 1er
rendez-vous de la Madeleine la
forteresse de Chevreuse vous plonge à la
fin du Moyen-Âge avec la découverte de
l'artisanat du 15e siècle calligraphie
soin du linge monnayage un voyage dans
le temps signé à Elsa benotchi et Regina
dès que j'enlève mon pouce
l'objet pleure c'est le champ de fleurs
partir à la découverte des objets et des
techniques artisanales du 15e siècle
c'est l'enjeu de ce premier rendez-vous
de la Madeleine un cadre idéal celui du
château de la Madeleine construit en
1483 achevreuse pour rendre l'expérience
vivante des médiateurs vêtus en tenue
d'époque présente dans ces murs leurs
techniques
monnayage taillage de pierre et même
calligraphie l'artisanat est à l'honneur
on souhaite élargir les publics
développer la fréquentation et proposer
à chacun une réelle expérience de visite
en plus évidemment de la découverte de
ce magnifique site mais ce qui nous fait
nous vibrer encore plus c'est de
d'essayer de leur vraiment de d'être des
passeurs de savoir et de et de les de
leur faire découvrir la vie quotidienne
des gens au plus proche de ce qui peut
de ce que ça pouvait être dans la
réalité conçu par le département des
Yvelines l'immersion dans cette
forteresse du Moyen-Âge permet à tous
d'en connaître davantage sur les temps
anciens j'ai trouvé ça super chouette
que il propose des ateliers sur les
artisanat pour que les enfants puissent
le découvrir
pour découvrir sous un autre angle la
vie médiévale le château de la Madeleine
propose d'autres rendez-vous ouvert à
tous et gratuits alors à vos agendas les
27 et 28 mai découvrez la médecine du
Moyen-âge les 10 et 11 juin prochain
partez à la rencontre des chevaliers
lors de la guerre des centres et le
weekend des 7 et 8 octobre les Vikings
vous attendent
désolé cristal évidemment mais on pourra
poursuivre la conversation largement
après cette émission c'est une Charles
comme tous les jeudis alors d'habitude
c'est Gabriel Gontier qui vient mais là
ce soir c'est vous qui vous prêtez à
l'exercice vous nous livrez votre
sélection des idées de sortie on peut
aller faire de la randonnée mais il y a
d'autres idées aussi à faire dans les
Yvelines avec un week-end du 8 mai
prolongé et week-end qui dit week-end du
8 mai dit aussi commémoration d'une date
importante prolongé
justement c'est dû au jour férié du 8
mai à cette date ont commémore
l'anniversaire de la victoire des Alliés
face à l'Allemagne nazie le 8 mai 1945
45 date qui marque la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en Europe comme chaque
année un hommage sera rendu aux victimes
de la guerre regardez le programme qui
s'affiche à 50 ans en Yvelines attention
aux horaires qui sont variables on
retrouve Élancourt par exemple à 10h45
sur le parvis de la ferme des mousseux
trappes aux monuments morts à 10h ou
encore la verrière au cimetière à 10h
également on continue vos idées avec du
sport oui de badminton plus précisément
ce week-end ce sera les phases finales
du Top 12 de championnats de France
organisé par les volants d'Élancourt
elle se dérouleront au Palais des Sports
de la Ville réuniront les quatre
meilleurs clubs français de la saison et
demi finale auront lieu le vendredi 5 à
partir de 13h30 la petite finale et la
finale le 6 à respectivement 11h et 15h
le titre de champion de France offrira
le droit de représenter le pays lors de
la Coupe d'Europe des Clubs les tarifs
des billets vont de 3 à 8 euros
réservation sur le site du championnat
un atelier d'écriture ça se passe à la
médiathèque du canal de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux oui tout à fait
pas de syndrome de la page blanche à la
médiathèque du canal si vous souhaitez
améliorer votre plume elle vous propose
un atelier d'écriture tout public sur le
thème du hasard pas de niveau Reiki
confirmé comme débutant sont les
bienvenus et l'accès est en termes
entièrement libre et gratuit alors
prenez vos stylos et vos calepins ce
sera demain vendredi 5 mai de 15h30 à
17h la réservation est néanmoins
conseillée une fois qu'on a fait
travailler nos méninges on peut aller se
relaxer se détendre devant un spectacle
du Théâtre c'est ça
est une troupe 50 chinoise qui se
produit régulièrement sur le territoire
elle propose un spectacle le dimanche 7
mai à 20h30 à l'Espace de Coville de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux la pièce un
problème une solution mais en scène des
personnes de plusieurs générations pour
parler de problématiques liés à leur à
leur âge à leur statut ou à la société
ils seront encadrés par des
scientifiques qui vont s'efforcer de
trouver des solutions des solutions un
peu fantasmes fantasques à leurs
problèmes un spectacle avec beaucoup
d'humour et d'émotions le tarif et de 7
euros c'est gratuit pour les moins de 5
ans la réservation est obligatoire
rendez-vous sur le site Internet de la
compagnie si vous nous proposez aussi un
stage de photographie
6 mai de 14h à 17h à la Maison de
l'Environnement de Manille les hameaux
si vous aimez la nature et la
photographie ce stage gratuit d'un
après-midi est fait pour vous Sébastien
biais photographe spécialisé dans
l'illustration de la nature patrimoniale
du parc naturel de la Haute Vallée de
Chevreuse vous proposera son
savoir-faire et son expérience il vous
montrera comment capturer les plus beaux
clichés de la faune envir donc pas vos
appareils photos et votre paire de
jumelles les réservations sont néanmoins
conseillées également les informations
sur le site Internet de
Magny-les-Hameaux historique et insolite
direction la bibliothèque centrale de
Versailles elle est installée depuis
1803 dans les anciens bâtiments de
l'hôtel des Affaires étrangères et de la
marine de Louis XV c'est une
bibliothèque classée à dispose de 700
000 volumes et un fond patrimonial de
près de 100.000 volumes hérités des
collections du château de Versailles ce
samedi 6 mai de 10h30 à 12h ou de 14h à
15h30 je vous propose de partir à la
découverte de ce bâtiment et de
l'histoire des collections qu'il abrite
anecdotes et petits secrets vous
attendent pendant la visite les
inscriptions sont obligatoires pour y
participer votre choix autour de la
table pour le week-end Christelle j'ai
bien compris que c'était la rando
village ça semblait vous intéresser oui
complètement
c'est complètement insolite et ça donne
envie donc oui oui
dimanche est-ce qu'il y a une sélection
de la sélection pour vous je vais sortir
de mes idées de sortie je pense que
j'irai la randonnée aussi
votre sélection la petite visite
insolite de la Bibliothèque centrale de
Versailles qui a l'air effectivement
très sympathique en tout cas si vous
avez prévu de vous rendre ailleurs en
dehors des Yvelines pour le week-end en
province vigilance le trafic on vous le
disait tout à l'heure s'annonce
compliqué en ce week-end de fin des
vacances de printemps et weekend
également prolongé du 8 mai ce vendredi
Bison Futé voir rouge dans le sens des
départs dans la région des difficultés
qui commenceront dès la fin de matinée
dans les Yvelines au niveau des
autoroutes A10 à 13 et à 86 la situation
restera très difficile jusqu'en fin de
soirée pour la journée de samedi c'est
Orange dans les dans le sens des départs
ça risque de boucher jusqu'en début
d'après-midi dimanche la situation
s'inverse la couleur orange concernera
cette fois-ci le sens des retours des
ralentissements devraient se faire
ressentir des milieux de l'après-midi
sur l'autoroute A10 et enfin en ce lundi
férié Bison Futé voir rouge dans le sens
des retours prévoyez de rentrer en
matinée pour éviter les complications
car elle devrait se poursuivre jusque
dans la soirée un temps d'attente
important et prévu notamment au niveau
des barrières de péage
et en ce qui concerne les prévisions
météo pour la journée de vendredi demain
le temps va se dégrader peu à peu un
ciel parsemé le matin avec des nuages et
peut-être quelques éclaircies côté
thermomètre il fera 14 degrés dans les
secteurs Nord et Centre du département
13 degrés à Rambouillet ça vire à
l'orage dans l'après-midi les Yvelines
sont placés en vigilance jaune par Météo
France entre 14h et 21h soyez vigilants
elle est température sont un peu plus
fraîches qu'aujourd'hui 19 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans eversize 18
degrés dans le sud des Yvelines alors
réponse est-ce qu'il y aura du beau
temps dimanche pour la randovillage et
bien la réponse tout de suite avec
Thomas Fletcher qui va prendre les
commandes à présent de la météo pour
vous présenter à sa manière les
prévisions météo du weekend c'est dans
alors quoi de beau
alors quoi de beau ce week-end c'est la
fin des vacances dans les Yvelines
j'espère que vous avez bien profité moi
en tout cas là j'étais au max du profit
j'espère que j'ai profité pour ceux qui
pouvaient pas profiter
lundi 8 mai c'est férié petit week-end
prolongé on pourra profiter pour ceux
qui peuvent profiter moi en tout cas je
ne peux plus profiter samedi il pleut
dans les Yvelines dimanche il pleut pas
mais lundi il pleut une belle rentrée
quoi aujourd'hui pour ce micro-trottoir
on va parler de la journée
internationale du mot de passe mais
avant ça une petite page de jeu concours
n'hésitez pas à participer
avec un stylo du 60
[Musique]
tu verras tu iras ta meilleure vie mes
stylos de couleur différent pour écrire
une histoire passionnante c'est super
stylo écrivent à l'encre bleue
différents coloris sont disponibles bleu
et bleu vert et blanc et blanc vert et
blanc pour participer
identifier un comparse dans les com de
commentaires seront tirés au sort tentez
votre chance smiley good luck les
gagnants seront contactés sur Instagram
le réseau social qui appartient à Mark
Zuckerberg en cas de casque du présent
veuillez vous référer au mail vraiment à
gmail.com en fait samedi c'est la
journée mondiale du mot de passe est-ce
que vous avez des mots de passe nous
partager la des conseils de mot de passe
c'est à dire
j'essaie de changer assez régulièrement
régulièrement tout à fait c'est la
première fois que je sais déjà il y a
une journée du sais pas ça c'est nouveau
pour moi
dans le téléphone parce que ça m'inspire
la journée mondiale du mot de passe
c'est que ça doit être une journée où on
distribue plus de serrure que de clés
comme les applications quand j'ai besoin
de savoir je demande à un jeune je sais
que ils connaissent ils vont me dire ils
vont m'expliquer après là c'est bon
est-ce que vous avez des techniques moi
j'utilise un seul mot de passe depuis
plus de 15 ans le prénom de ma mère et
le prénom de mon père en majuscule avec
les dates de leur naissance respective
on peut avoir le nom de votre père le
nom de votre nom avec ça on ouvre quoi
ça ton mot de passe changer ça me dit
alors pour la journée mondiale du mot de
passe c'est ça c'est exactement ça
effectivement nous avons prévu
effectivement un rassemblement secret
dont le lieu sera
la nature du Dieu sera délivrée
sur les réseaux sociaux le plus
tardivement possible là je mets le flou
je vous en supplie
donc rassemblement de la secte du mot de
passe durant laquelle effectivement nous
sacrifierons des mots de passe on après
de six mois attention c'est pas évident
comment on rejoint si imaginons j'ai un
beau mot de passe à cramer alors il faut
absolument que ce soit le vôtre que vous
souhaitiez effectivement délivrer ça
c'est très important le consentement
c'est très important en délivrant
effectivement vos coordonnées votre
groupe Rhésus et votre pointure gauche
avec en recommandé mais sans accuser de
réception sur tout puisque nous ne
accusons absolument personne
ok en fait on m'a conseillé d'utiliser
des longs phrases sans espace mais avec
des points c'est pas du tout pas mal
j'ai déjà mes idées moi
ah bah ça reste un mot de passe
et moi je bip au montage comment ah oui
vous pouvez le dire
alors quoi de beau
vous avez eu chacun à sa technique en
tout cas Hervé a priori pas de pluie
dimanche bonne nouvelle ça m'a coûté
quelques sièges vous avez pris bonne
note des quelques tips conseils pour les
mots de passe vous avez peut-être les
vôtres Christelle des points de
suspension et voilà pour ce nouveau
numéro alors quoi de beau hein des
prévisions météo décalé de Thomas à
Fletcher il va aussi à la rencontre des
yvelinois à chaque fois pour leur poser
des questions sur un terme précis merci
à lui merci à Mathis aussi qui a
participé tout directement alors sur ce
alors quoi de beau Mathis qui était
stagiaire cette semaine dans la
rédaction de TV 78 merci également à
vous autour de la table Céline
Christelle Hervé d'abord été avec moi
durant cette émission c'est la fin du 7
8 merci de votre fidélité le 7 8 qui
revient dès mardi prochain 18h en direct
pour une nouvelle émission d'ici là
portez vous bien belle soirée et
excellent weekend sur TV 78
[Musique]